uh let's talk about the love triangles
because you know there is a little i
mean it is a drama series right
there's a lot
right you always need the love triangles
this season who do you think as a fan of
the show now and knowing what you know
who do you think she is meant
for well i don't think it's any of her
loves in the first season
that she is only 29 years old has not
dated in six years she needs some more
experience we need to
practice trying to find the balance
right so she's trying she's getting out
there but training wheels so it's gotta
practice she's gotta try and all these
boys that keep distracting her from
trying to make partner i mean we love
the drama but keep it coming
being on the partner track is how you
find out who you really are it's
cutthroat and i'm so close you had
worked non-stop for six years it's in
the back do you really think you can
start dating new york's most eligible
trust friend without anyone noticing
now that i'm on the suncorp case i may
never have time for date again don't let
this place take you dry and grid i feel
like with any new series it's easy to
try to draw comparisons to other shows
just to kind of figure out what it is
right and i will say you're in good
company because this show's being
compared to other series like sex and
the city suits i'm even getting kind of
like emily and paris fives what do you
make of that what do you think i'm
honored these are
those i love so it's such an honor
i feel like you're right it's tough it's
tough shooting a pilot or a new show and
trying to figure out the feel or the
color the sound the music now that i've
seen the show i'm like oh okay how would
you describe it
it's definitely different i feel like
it's not exactly a show that we've seen
before it feels very fresh and new there
are elements that i feel like of course
we see some similarities but i feel like
it's got a lot of moments for me that
feel like movie moments it's very fun it
is ingrid marching through manhattan
trying to make it in this city and so i
love the sexman city um comparison
because obviously love that show and
there's so many great moments in it but
this is still a drama and there is still
real things happening it's very
relatable it's tough there's moments
where we might be crying we might be
angry or we might be laughing it's like
this roller coaster of emotions it is it
is and i feel like just as people are
now watching um the screeners and i'm
getting like text i love that people are
angry right happy people are arguing
i love it it's the emotions that we want
i have no idea how hard it is to be a
person of color at this point
when we're at the top we push them inch
by inch i will not measure progress in
inches the emotions are very diverse but
also i feel like the one thing that is i
would say probably the one thing we all
can agree on is that we're all rooting
for ingrid you know like we're about
she's this first generation
korean-american woman really trying to
like carve her own path and even though
she makes it look easy and doesn't let
people see her sweat we all know that's
not reality right i mean how much could
you relate to ingrid in this character i
mean there are so many
moments i relate to ingrid or so many
times where i'm like oh we hate how
invisible she feels or how she's doing
all the hard work not getting the credit
being sort of pushed aside or overlooked
or all those you know we all hate the
misogyny and the picture this down there
are so many moments where i'm just like
oh i hate it but i love that we show it
that's special it is rare that we get to
see it slowly see it some of these
moments that i'm like oh my gosh it's so
long and painful but it's good we need
that and how great is it that we get to
see this today i mean this is not a show
that only asian american women are going
to relate to this is a show that
minorities men female anyone in a tough
field where they're the minority will
relate i feel like there's a little
something for everyone and every
character
is on a journey we see everyone battling
themselves battling their identity or
what they want who they want who they
are ugh
it really does have something for
everybody including you know for people
who loved with sex in the city we got to
get like everything that's going on with
those characters in the city but also
the fashion and i feel like the fashion
also tells its own story in this show
let's talk about the clothes how fun was
it for you to work with the costumer on
this we love the clothes i mean all of
the characters have such a distinct
style and i feel like really special
especially for tyler rachel and ingrid
like the trio
i love that their style is so good
they're really different you know i
always say style wise i'm like oh i love
rachel in her chic chic black i love
tyler in his fabulous suits tailoring
right i did i never
wow i just speechless did not realize
how much of a difference good tailoring
can do right and that's so true for the
world she's into i feel like you really
have to have like a tailored look you
know you gotta look good
and even for ingrid i mean
some of these suits who knew like a
vintage valentino suit okay or that
little dior moment she's got these great
looks that are fitted so well and i feel
like it's very nice to see a woman who
is in a position of power
it is strong and brilliant who isn't
afraid to show her feminine side yes not
afraid to show a bit of softness because
that's who she is i think the fact that
we first see ingrid and pink in a sea of
gray says everything it really sets up
what we're about to watch you know i
loved it like i didn't see that but they
saw that like georgia costumers
everybody involved saw that and
now as a viewer watching it i'm like oh
you guys are brilliant it's instantly
iconic you know that first look it's
amazing yes honey we know you're not a
part of the movie but i want to ask you
about teen wolf do you have a message
for fans who are maybe a little bummed
that we're not gonna be able to see kira
this time around uh well one i will
always love the fans and i'm so thankful
for the moment that i got to be kira and
thankful that fans still remember her
and yeah i mean it's okay she still
lived and she had her time so hey watch
partner track now i was just about to
say that now
you can see arden in the city now y'all
right i feel like this is so fun and now
we need a whole season 10 episodes
i'm gonna need a second season i'm just
putting it out there let's manifest it
we're manifesting it
[Music]
you